how long have you smoked I've been
smoking cigarette since I was seven
years old damn my dad was like that my
dad tells everybody I've been smoking
since I was eight you want me to get
this [__] up my dad got arrested when he
was nine I think my he tried to burn
down his house myad I think he was I
think this ran away from the arm man but
he can't you know how you get a home
pass I guess yeah and then ran away to
New York New Orleans cuz he didn't want
to go back so I guess during the time
like as he was at the house M I used to
be watching that smoking cigarettes and
every time he throw that I grab it you
grab it and you smoke what was left yeah
damn yeah I did that one time my dad
threw a cigarette down I was probably
like seven and I remember I picked that
up I took a hit and I th I was coughing
so much I threw up and my mom was like
see that's what the you get picking up
cigarette and ever since then I was I
was out on it man I was out on it I just
want to be better than